Hey, Vsauce. Michael here on a couch with
Vi Hart and Henry from MinutePhysics.
Now, of all the people on this couch I probably
have the least famous hands, but the most
hairy.
So here we go.
My hand, a mouse trap and how about a phantom
at 3,000 frames a second.
Let's do this.
The  slow-motion looks fantastic.
But right now I'm in Dallas visiting my sister
and for some things you can do online now
guys, check these out.
First of all, instead of watching a guy solve
a Rubik's Cube with his nipples,
have some fun frolicking in Meow-Mania.
And if it's not cute enough for you, Ponycorns
is a game written and voiced by a small child.
But if you're not a fan of Ponycorns, well,
try it anyway, because YOLO.
The game.
BrandonDSmithTV showed me this simple little
platform that truly investigates the
"You Only Live Once" philosophy.
And for an even darker challenge,
check out "Ebony."
I love these things.
Clever puzzle sites that require you to think differently.
It gets quite challenging, so good luck.
And relax by enjoying some 3D panoramas from
the air.
Choose a spot in the sky and then use your
keyboard and mouse to look around.
Or feel around with your hand.
Your sticky hand.
Bryt9 brought me here.
And don't forget the other Coke sitelets,
like this one, where you can tease a bottle
oh, so close to some dominoes.
Now, you can also do experiments in these
virtual worlds with Little alchemy.
I've got an app like this on my phone, but
your browser can play too.
Drag and combine elements to see how many
new things you can create, combine in creative
ways to generate them all.
And if you're sick of fast Internet,
reminisce with dialupsound.com.
Says-It makes things say whatever you want.
I particularly enjoy the concert ticket, the
warning sign and the gas station sign.
Let's take a break from making things and
watch Neave[.com].
He's got amazing things I've covered before,
but SmartWentCody brought his TV to my attention.
It's weird, curiosity-peeking clips that change
for your pleasure or whenever you click.
But for a bigger cute factor, be like MinecraftTurtle
and watch this Ustream of kittens.
They're kind of tired now, but in the morning
they're super fun.
Oh and this inverse grapher will turn whatever
you type into some equations that graph it.
But let's talk lines.
Here's a 3D line flying game where you control
the direction and the shape you leave behind.
Make knots and coils and use your previous
path as an obstacle course for your future.
Okay, this is something that I love.
Have you ever tapped the melody to a song
with your finger on a table, for instance,
and asked a friend to guess the song, only to
find that by listening to the tapping alone
your friend cannot even come close to guessing,
while in your own mind it seems obvious.
Well, psychological studies have been done
on this phenomenon and it turns out that the
big difference is knowledge.
The fact that you know what melody to expect
makes it difficult for you to understand why
the task is so difficult to others.
Now that said, Bored.com has built this.
Songtapper.
A machine that is learning how to understand
tapping with a space bar.
Check this out.
I'll tap a song.
Not bad.
Let's talk about something that's off-lying.
The Moon.
How big is the Moon in the sky?
What sized coin would cover the Moon if held
at arm's length?
Funny enough, the Moon is a lot smaller in
the sky than you'd think.
Different visual illusions that we still don't
quite understand influence how big we perceive
the Moon to be in the sky, but in reality,
the size of the Moon in the sky is only about
the size of a hole punch in a piece of paper
held at arm's length.
That's tiny.
Alban brought up Sinuous, which lets you relax
as you mouse around as a line that must avoid
dots while acquiring shields and other goodies.
And share your mouse-moving skills like Josh
with this Swedish armed forces game.
You're added to a team of real people and
given a colour.
Here I'm the red cursor and the other ones
are other people playing at the same time.
Then complete tasks in order to help your
team mates.
[Voice:] Which colour was the shape?
[Voice:] Correct, yellow.
[Voice:] Status increased.
Make a mistake and they suffer.
Finally, a very special long DONG for you
guys.
An entire list of every single DONG I've ever
covered in an episode of DONG.
We've put them all in one place, check all
of those out.
Watch all the previous episodes if you haven't
already.
And I will be at Comic-Con later this week.
I hope to see some of you there.
I'm on the Dark Matters panel on Friday.
And as always,
thanks for watching.